[Music]
from being the Bread Basket of the world
a powerful meat exporter and having huge
reserves of gas oil and lithium to being
permanently submerged in a loop of
constant financial and economic problems
this is the Eternal Argentine
contradiction to say that the country is
on the verge of bankruptcy is no longer
news to anyone is it and yet this is
where we are
10 May 2023 Argentina is going broke to
stall a full-on currency collapse
Central Bank has more liabilities than
assets on balance sheet 15 February 2023
two out of three children in Argentina
are more or deprived of basic rights 31
March 2023 Argentina adds 1 million new
poor people in 2022 up to 39.2 percent
of the population well in the midst of
such a context the open simultaneous and
compulsory primary elections or Paso
using its Spanish acronym were held on
the 13th of August it was a sort of
election where all political forces are
obliged to participate in order to elect
or ratify their candidates and guess
what the results have been a real
bombshell the argentines have said
enough
Against All Odds Javier melaye a
Libertarian Outsider who came to
Argentine politics in 2019 has won this
particular elections
[Applause]
as you can see he has not only become
the most voted candidate individually
but with more than 30 percent of the
votes he is well ahead of the rest of
the political forces
and that's not all after years and years
of political dominance now peronism the
ideology that has marked the history of
Argentina for the last 90 years seems to
be mortally wounded it has obtained one
of its worst electoral results in
history so the question is why what
could explain this debacle why did
Alberto Fernandez's government become so
unpopular what could this political
tsunami mean for Argentina will
libertarian Javier melee become the new
president of the Republic visual politic
Community we are going to examine all
the answers to these questions and in an
upcoming video here on visualpolitik we
will also see what exactly this new
political lion hopes for Argentina so
let's get cracking
[Applause]
[Music]
Argentina has not only been the country
of crises for a year it was also the
flagship country of political
instability between 1930 and 1976 the
country experienced no fewer than six
coup d'etats you could say that in those
times the military had little patience
on average Argentine suffered a coup
d'etat every 2 800 days nevertheless
this situation changed completely after
1983 when the military was forced to
abandon the executive after the defeat
in the malvinas
foreign
of democracy meant the return to the
most basic constitutional guarantees the
times of censorship and repression were
left behind yet although the first
president elected in this new Democratic
stage Raul Ricardo alfonsin was quite
successful in rebuilding political
institutions he was an economic disaster
in 1989 when he left office the country
was registering an annual inflation rate
of over 4 900
of course then came the rebound as we've
already told you here on visualpolitik
during Carlos menem's presidency between
1989 and 1999 Argentina's economy took
off like a rocket that was until
Argentina's Eternal addiction to public
spending sent everything to hell again
in 2001 everything collapsed president
de la Rua had to resign the Argentine
economy defaulted and a wave of popular
indignation broke out in the streets
with a shout kick them all out and yes
at this point the Congress was also
stormed then
[Music]
in the next elections in 2003 the most
voted candidate in the first round was
once again Carlos menem but with no real
chances of winning he decided not to run
in the second round Nestor Kirchner took
over the helm the kirchnerism era began
since then more than 20 years have
passed of which only four have had a
non-paronist government we are referring
of course to that of Mauricio mackley
between 2015 and 2019. the rest of the
time perronism kushnerism has been
dominant in 2011 Christina Fernandez de
Kirchner even won re-election with 54 of
the votes in the first round hers became
the candidacy with the third highest
electoral support in Argentine history
kirchner's peruism had become an empire
in itself and then in 2019 after
Maurizio macri the first non-paronis
Democratic leader to complete his term
in office in the last 90 years the
peronist kirchnerist Coalition El
ferente de Toros swept the polls again
it seemed the argentines had missed them
even so this mandate became such an
uphill battle that all political capital
and power began to evaporate so the
question is what exactly explains the
debacle that perunism is suffering well
let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
cfk and the piranhist debacle
Christina Fernandez de Kirchner For
Better or For perhaps worse has been a
turning point in Argentine politics
after the death of her husband in
October of 2010 cfk took over the Reigns
of the country and has since become one
of the most controversial political
figures not only in Argentina but also
in all of Latin America and perhaps the
whole world we are talking about a
political leader who has never ceased to
be in the Limelight and who has always
done everything possible to have her
hands on the strings of power for
example in 2019 she bet that Alberto
Fernandez a former collaborator of hers
and one of the peronist's most critical
of her profile would be the presidential
candidate while she pooled the strings
from the vice presidency that at least
was her intentionally
president
we are talking about a guy who for years
has been repeating accusations like this
with almost 13 million votes peruism
swept the board argentines put their
trust in this unusual Jewel and a second
round was not even necessary this was
the beginning of one of the most
complicated and difficult legislators in
living memory on the 10th of December
2019 Alberto Fernandez became president
the idea was that Alberto would
contribute to moderate heronism and the
truth is that his mandate began with a
very high popularity rating however the
first storm would not take long to
appear on the horizon
just three months after reaching the
casa rosada the covid-19 pandemic broke
out the Argentine government then
decided to establish one of the longest
quarantines in the world at first in the
midst of the quarantine the confidence
in government index soared to a 15-year
High nevertheless this sentiment soon
turned around it then began a free fall
that has continued to this day
not surprisingly the pandemic and the
application of a very long quarantine
took its toll on the economy and to that
we have to add news like this political
impact due to the photo showing Alberto
Fernandez celebrating in Olivos in full
quarantine the result is that in 2021
the government was already politically
speaking on the rules practically at its
limit Alberto Fernandez was less popular
than a pop quiz on a Monday morning the
popular Legend of purunism was suddenly
fading away and when the legislative
elections came you can imagine what
happened
the ruling party had given itself a slap
in the face it was an electoral
catastrophe especially because even an
important perona's strongholds in the
interior of the country the support of
ferente De Toros at the ruling Coalition
was not very strong more importantly it
was a preamble to what was to come among
other reasons because in politics when
you win and govern it's very easy to
make friends but when you lose well then
the problems and the stabs multiply
which is exactly what happened vice
president Christina Fernandez herself
issues a letter placing all of the
responsibility on the president I
pointed out that I believed that a wrong
fiscal adjustment policy was being
carried out which was having a negative
impact on the economic activity and
therefore on society as a whole and that
undoubtedly this was going to have
electoral consequences I did not say it
once I got tired of saying it and not
only to the president of the nation the
answer was always that it was not so
that I was wrong and that according to
the polls we were going to win very well
in the elections cfk's public letter 16
September 2021. that was the point of a
new return from that moment on the
government broke down completely and
then every man for himself face began
suddenly we saw ministers criticizing
the government itself Miss Kay earring
on all four corners how disastrous
Fernandez was and all kirchnerism coming
together as a block pushing for a change
in their economic policy
foreign
the situation reached such a point that
in March of 2022 when the minister of
economy Martin Guzman managed to reach
an agreement with the IMF to restructure
the Argentine debt some of the
kirchnerist deputies voted against it in
Congress this put the talks with the IMF
on the brink of collapse visual politic
viewers the fratrosage will struggle
only made Fernandez need votes from the
opposition but ended with the
resignation of the minister of economy
himself and the total implosion of the
government and of peruism things were so
bad that Alberto and Christina tried a
last-ditch solution a final bullet with
the government on the verge of default
and inflation skyrocketing they agreed
to put Sergio Masa an influential
politician and then president of the
Chamber of deputies in charge of the
ministry of economy and not only that
they also gave him the ministry of
production and the Ministry of
Agriculture in other words basically at
the time when the economy was everything
they gave him the keys to the government
and what was the result then well
nothing changed things went from bad to
worse and take note because the
government's perspective at least
publicly is very different according to
them the problem Argentina's real
problem is that the country had been
doing too well yes yes too well that was
their professional assessment
s
which of course contrasts completely to
with the social reality to give you an
idea things are so bad that it is no
exaggeration to say today that Argentina
is a depressed country one of the
world's major Powers at the beginning of
the 20th century today it is struggling
not to fall too far behind countries
like Bulgaria or Romania this country
continues to break records and one in
four people already have symptoms of
anxiety and depression evidently the
poor economic and professional situation
has a lot to do with all of this as much
as the government insists on the
contrary
that is to say we have in front of us an
endless economic crisis a tremendously
unpopular president an official done
broken into hateful factions and a
government seemed to live on another
planet so my question is do you think
that's the end of it well you could not
be more wrong to top it all off in
December of 2022 the courts ruled on one
of the many corruption chases against
Christina Fernandez de Kirchner she was
firmly convicted
and of course given such a background we
cannot be surprised that peruism has
collapsed the disaster has been colossal
even by the standards of Argentine
politics in fact taking into account all
the events what can I say the fact that
peronism still continues to obtain
almost 30 percent of the votes is
surprising almost incomprehensible even
but even so it's third place in the
payaso is a true reflection of
everything that has happened of course
the collapse of peruism is not only
explained by its own mistakes in this
case the opposition also had a lot to do
with it check this out
[Music]
a much more combative opposition
visual politic viewers despite the
Electoral disaster of 2019 when the
peronists took back the Reigns of the
country gambiermos the platform that had
raised Mercurio macri did not dissolve
or fragment it changed its name to
juntos por El Cambio together for Change
and despite many internal battles
remained United this allowed them to
face the government with much more
strength this was key to their victory
in the latest legislative elections in
2021. for the first time in a long time
the alternative to peruism was not
divided in addition two very different
proposals were presented for the 2023
primaries on the one hand horizio
Rodriguez who had been head of the
government of the city of Buenos Aires
for eight years Loretta has a moderate
profile and has shown himself to be more
open to dialogue with peronism to seek
common ground which earned him the
nickname of paloma or peace dove on the
other hand there was Patricia bulrich
former security minister from Mercurio
Mercury and candidate with a lot fewer
problems when it comes to sticking it to
the unions and kirchnerism dulrich was
the Falcon and now the Paso has decided
that she will be the candidate of El
Cambio
[Music]
of course in the end neither She nor her
political formation were the main
players of the Paso the protagonist and
the great winner was undoubtedly Javier
Miller an outsider Economist who has
turned his campaign into an enormous
rally not against the government but
against the whole political model of
Argentina
foreign
[Applause]
del Mundo
sin embargo
a new momento
La Clase
Argentinos
Malay promises to put an end to all of
Argentina's economic ills he talks about
dollarizing the economy abolishing a
large part of the state luring taxes and
in short breaking with what has been
Argentina's economic political model for
the last 70 80 or even 90 years
inflation
with an aggressive and tremendously
ambitious plan one that is practically
revolutionary he achieved an enormous
Triumph
[Music]
hardly anyone saw it coming but Malay
won more than 30 of the votes he won in
16 provinces and won some of the most
popular neighborhoods as well as the
most prosperous towns of Argentina even
so wait a minute because Malay is not
yet president yes we could already talk
about him as a favorite candidate but
there is still a race ahead on the one
hand melee will have to expand his
electoral ceiling to become president he
needs to get more votes the Paso have
left the political landscape wide open
only 2.8 points separate the three major
political formations and here there are
two contrasting circumstances on the one
hand melee's dermatic profile may not
fit very well with the electorate that
seeks a change but not a revolution
which surprisingly is still very large
in fact voter abstention was very high
almost a third of the electorate stayed
home and the game in October may be
somewhat different remember that in
Argentina voting is compulsory and
turnout usually exceeds 80 more than 11
points higher than the turnout we have
seen in this sort of pre-election
between 10 and 13 points more which in a
scenario so close to thirds could change
everything yet on the other hand what
the hell Malay has won the Paso and
again in politics victory means Victory
as of today a vote for this candidate is
already a perfectly useful vote
Argentina
[Applause]
but even if he were to become president
he would face another major problem
you see in Argentina the Chamber of
deputies removes half of its members
every two years and the Senate only
renews 30 at a time that is to say a
government that comes to power from zero
without previous blocks in the
parliament would have a very difficult
time making significant changes be that
as it may what is clear is that
Argentina is facing a seismic change
argentines have said enough is enough
for the first time peruism has collapsed
and for the first time the alternative
is clearly in the majority one way or
another everything indicates that
Argentina is going to change but we will
talk about all of that in a future video
now the question is will this be the end
of peruism who will finally win the
presidency do you think that Argentina
will manage to move forward will the
libertarian Flags reach the casa Rosara
and if you're watching us from the land
of the Gaucho which candidate do you
support leave us your opinions and your
answers in the comments below and let's
open a respectful debate and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to all of
us here at visualpolitik if you haven't
already done so all the best I hope you
enjoyed the video and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you